One of the areas where Donald Trump has really
bamboozled a lot of people when it comes to
his
knowledge of an issue is trade and economic
policy. This was something that if you go
back to the 2015 and 2016 Republican presidential
campaign, Donald Trump very early on, started
talking about China or Jina as he likes to
refer to it endlessly talking about how the
U S has losing the trade deals are bad. He
understands that he's going to fix it. He's
going to do the negotiations like a businessman
and all of this stuff. And because a lot of
other people he was talking to also don't
understand those issues. Um, he made a lot
of headway on the idea that he gets it and
he's going to fix it. And even if the supporters
didn't fully understand exactly what he was
going to do or how it was going to be good
for them, they fell for it. They were bamboozled.
And then when Donald Trump became the president
of the United States, he tricked his supporters
into thinking that the things he was doing
were good.
Right? The trade policy, the trade war with
China, the tax policy, which a lot of the
benefit was from changing the withholdings
tables and people thought they were having
more money than they file their taxes and
they actually paid more in tax for the year
in total. And all of it, um, seemed to make
sense to them. Oh yeah, Trump's doing great.
It's all good for us. But the truth is that
that was not at all the case. And I want to
take some time today to look at the news of
Donald Trump bragging about and his supporters
bragging about signing the U S China phase
one trade deal. What the hell does phase one
mean? What are they talking about? What is
this all about? So the day before yesterday,
Donald Trump and China's vice premier, Lou
hay signed the U S China phase one trade deal
in terms of tariffs.
This means very little, but we'll talk about
what it does do and what it doesn't do. Most
importantly, what it does not do. Signing
this phase one trade deal does not end the
trade war. Donald Trump has not lowered tariffs
on Chinese goods top line. That's the most
important thing to understand. Everything
else is more or less secondary to that. Really.
This was a photo op for Donald Trump. Here
is a little video, Trump making a huge deal
out of all of this. We're showing video of
the signing ceremony that the Trump white
house dreamed up. You know how they like to
do it with a whole bunch of people, Donald
Trump signing a bunch of copies, taking forever
to just write his name. It's all very weird,
but the important thing is what does the deal
do? One of the things that's in this phase
one deal is that it commits China to cracking
down on theft of American technology and corporate
secrets.
It's not nothing, okay, but in the context
of the failed trade war that Donald Trump
is waging, it's pretty underwhelming. The
deal includes a $200 billion spending package
by China to close a little bit of the trade
imbalance with the United States. Now, I want
to get back to that because we have that trade
imbalance for a reason. Donald Trump objectively
cites it as a, as the, as a deficit by deficit.
I mean he'd sites it as a negative thing.
Um, but our economy is actually based on that
and we'll talk about that later. Phase one
deal that was signed, commits China to avoiding
currency manipulation to gain an advantage.
And it has a system for enforcing that. Of
course, then you've got a debate whether the
currency was manipulated to gain an advantage
or not. And then you're in five years of arguing
about that. The really important thing is
what's missing from this deal?
This deal does nothing to address Chinese
hacking of American companies. That's something
that supposedly they were going to be talking
about and dealing with. It does nothing about
that. The deal does nothing about the subsidies
from the Chinese state that if fueled Chinese
companies around the world, arguably to the
detriment of American companies. Now, I'm
not taking a position here on that. That's
a debate in and of itself about what makes
sense and what doesn't make sense. Protectionism,
Amera, uh, economic nationalism, et cetera.
But they said this was one of the things they
wanted to deal with and they are not dealing
with it in phase one of this deal. It also
does not end the trade war. It does not remove
the disastrous tariffs. Now, of course the
Trump administration says all of that is going
to come in phase two. So really the headline
here is something has been passed.
Donald Trump can claim it as a win. People
who don't know much will believe that it's
a win and maybe when you go interview Trump
supporters at rallies and say, what does Trump
accomplished that you like? They'll say, well,
he did the phase one trade deal. Even if in
reality it doesn't do very much now to be
charitable. If I want it to be as charitable
as possible about this phase one deal, I could
say signing something, anything, as long as
it has even a tiny step forward, it could
generate momentum for doing something bigger.
Okay. I mean, that's the most charitable analysis
and time will tell whether it's a good analysis,
whether it actually leads to anything further.
But again, it's just an opportunity for Trump
to brag. And here he is doing it.
The agreement tears down major market barriers
for us, food and agricultural exports. China
will now welcome American beef and pork, poultry,
seafood, rice, dairy, infant formula, animal
feed, biotechnology, and much, much more.
So you get the idea. Now let me talk a little
bit about the trade imbalance. This is really
important to understand and uh, I've, I've
mentioned it in passing before. Donald Trump
constantly talks about the trade deficit.
We're importing way more from China than we
are exporting to China and we've got to fix
this. You don't just fix that because our
economy for decades has been based on them
decades ago when outsourcing of labor started
to go elsewhere, when outsourcing of manufacturing
started to go elsewhere and we increasingly
became a service based economy. When you do
that, you are essentially deciding we are
going to prioritize cheap stuff from overseas
to fuel our economy rather than higher wages
and more expensive stuff that's produced locally.
So a different example, this is not a perfect
example, but a lot of people when they go
to Switzerland or they hear about Switzerland,
they go in, they have sticker shock.
A cheeseburger is 28 Swiss Franks. I remember
it like it was yesterday when I was in Zurich
a couple of years ago. I said, this must be
the best cheeseburger around. No, it was just
a normal cheeseburger. It's extremely expensive
for everything, but you have people who were
working within the U S would not be well paid
jobs earning a living wage, and it's a different
type of economy and things cost more. But
there's a higher standard of living. You have
a taxes used to fund a number of social services.
Okay? That's one way a company, a, a a country's
economy can go in the United States. The decision
was made and it doesn't have to be an explicit
decision where everybody says, we don't care
about wages. We want to keep prices down for
people and we're going to do it with cheap
stuff from China. That is what the economy
is based on.
So the idea that Donald Trump is going to
just fix the trade imbalance without realizing
that he has to completely restructure the
economy and undo decades of the economy being
organized in this way, to call it naive would
be a huge understatement. Remember that whenever
we talk about the trade deficit with China,
more smoke and mirrors, more lack of any real
understanding of economics or trade, but it's
all politics. It's something that Trump's
supporters, if they remember, it can say Trump
accomplished in order to justify voting for
him instead of whoever is the democratic nee
nominee in November, which is ultimately what
they want
to do.